[Music]  we will not accept North Korea as a  nuclear state North Korea has test-fired  missile this is clear provocation we're  sneaking around right on the edge of  international waters  the ancient killer who ordered me to  give the Americans everything they need  you will see the pilot right now this  sup is the best shot we've got it  completing our mission we are now in  control understand start taking it out  what is that this is your big secret I'm  alright babe we can put it in welcome  back 81 please respond  81 do you read me talk to me  we're upside down you're gonna be  crushed in a second  we are at the bottom of the ocean  if you do this we're tapping  we're all dead you're the reason that  we're in this mess now this is worth  dying for